Baron sluttish
the team that had hopes of learns Kevin
Durant Kyrie Irving and others as
Barrett is a guy that has made his way
to New York via the draft Barrett with
the left hand working against blue got
to the bucket and counted
RJ Barrett get a hand a little bit here
to start this game up Barrett on the LOB
and he's back cut Alonso trier as you
see the back screen by Mitchell
Robertson they clear the backside once
and a real force in the paint brought
the regular season for the Knicks Knox
hit his first three threes hits his
first one here tonight think of the fact
that they're having RJ parent handle a
lot almost running some point forward
here knock down the shot when you look
at the youth level in what they're doing
Harper it's missing the layup Braz Dacus
with a nice handle to e foul
Braz Dacus kicked it back out to Barrett
two on the shot clock got to get it off
inside and got it to Paul mr. Robinson
and actually couldn't get possession
gonna do a lot of work to get that shot
off the blow up front again spirit
got in his bag bye parent it'll be son's
basketball with five point eight to go
real confident and parent with a nice
defensive play they're beginning to the
Vegas summer league through two games
Kia from Alpharetta Georgia
Mitchell Robinson with the steal merit
to Knox but RJ Barrett diamond Kevin
Knox what he could do unselfish even
though he's a scorer so here's RJ
working against Thomas determined to get
to the cup and he says silence about
this mystery driving and look at the
strength for his size just to term it
takes the hit might have got fun
Cavanaugh yes going against Boucher a
bouncy big out of Oregon
RJ Barrett yes plus the foul locked one
left and obviously he's got to work on a
counter to going right but this is just
taking up the space create the bump and
then plan through the ball Barrett in
the knick most valuable player and
Defensive Player of the Year in the
d-league in only 28 games yeah Robinson
nice feet from bear and any lays it in
or Deloitte created that loose ball nice
hustle by Kadeem Allen chased down by
Barrett and here's Braz Dacus good
hustle five connects it was Hernandez
and the rebound by RJ Barrett has nine
rebounds and RJ Barrett puts it it
rebound on the ball pushed it
surveying the court driving it take it
away to my left I go right to the right
59th pick in the 2019 draft almost
mister of irrelevant as Mitchell
Robinson gets it to crawl over the rim
and he was fouled this was an NBA game
he's got a chance to play an NBA games
it'd be totally different for everyone
be as it as aggressive but he has a high
motor and some ability those are Jay
Baer to go with 13 points and 13 boards
Barrett he hit a three ladies and
gentlemen here's an athlete with your
problems stanky brass Degas Lambert's
down to five on the shot clock for
Morgan left-handed layup wouldn't go to
on Hernandez was stuffed saw Fred
vanvleet and Kyle Lowry playing at the
same time so I
right there's Kadeem Alan Robinson has a
mismatch passed up there in a good wood
kid can play it's a really nice pass the
rims there but he has fantastic camp
there's Barrett Phoenix Seattle San
Antonio there you go don't worry about
telling you nor Bell is a good defender
no bells a tough kid but no Val gets
abused just a guy didn't really have a
prominent role no Jake Barrett hits
another three ball close at least know
where they are nice move by Barrett he
seems so the following gets comfortable
then when you get comfortable you do
things like that Bart
he certainly has embraced the spotlight
of being in New York and being their top
first-round pick number think dockage
hit the nail on the head they've got
some young guys that they're trying to
develop and they're gonna try to get
into the mix in 2021 which Kauai has an
option for that year tear it off the
bounce got to scream from Robinson
nice kick out football movement and
bucket by the New York Knicks a guy like
RJ that's a pretty simple formula to
look at this keep trying to shoot over
Robinson just tempting shooters to shoot
it and he keeps winning those battles
Baron out top nice in and out dribble
with the off hand RJ parrot little sauce
on that one he's got 21
RJ Barrett dances inside and scores on
the line RJ his dad was growing played
at st. John's and played overseas
[Applause]
see a stick person about the game of
basketball and you know he's been very
helpful to the NBA the WNBA
Jarrod knocks down take us in and
Cavanaugh goes out more points than any
other player in Lipscomb District
Barrett to the rim lays it up and lays
it in Virginia Merritt aim the better
you're gonna get you are not a finished
product
he was really good he was a great 1717
and in Robinson would oppose the people
that come in the building is really what
makes that build insane and makes it hum
Oxford Paris against Jones takes him
inside in store today it's true that
they put on the Internet but what is
true is I had hopes not hop so I know
what block
[Applause]
Cavanaugh put the jump up the set of my
RJ berry by Wooten who has been a pogo
stick Li per year parents off high glass
must-see TV Memphis Tigers Knox Rises
Barrett for three RJ Barrett great way
to end it for him come get a win and
then have a good game Cavanaugh for
three well there's one assistant and
that'll be the end of the evening for RJ
Barrett fouling this assistant to
Cavanaugh what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content